meyer dans tpm payé lors de la séquence
du quart d'heure sans fil qu'on avait
parlé l'émission cauchemar en cuisine
diffusée sur m6 alors j'ai eu tous les
patrons m6 dernière là comme par sms et
caetera et en plate on avait notamment
reçu monica qui ne gardait pas vraiment
un bon souvenir de son passage dans le
programme on va vous donner la réponse
de m6 à tpm pays dans un instant c'est
vrai que c'est ce qui a fait le plus
parler aujourd'hui
regardez ce qui s'est passé hier hier
soir sur notre plateau monica une
restauratrice qui a participé à
l'émission cauchemar en cuisine sur m6
nous expliquer que le programme était
truquée et que la production avait tout
fait pour donner une mauvaise image de
son établissement et à des clientes
monique sont venus pour manger qu'ils
ont été refusés à l'entrée qu'il
laissait pas rentré j'ai eu une cliente
m'a dit monika j'ai dit que c'était pas
mon amendement est vrai dire aujourd'hui
monica est en colère contre m6 elle
tient la chaîne en partie responsable de
l'échec de son établissement qu'elle a
depuis dû fermer vivent aujourd'hui avec
le rsa et elle a même fait une demande à
la chaîne en direct
moi j'aimerais juste qu'ils arrêtent
nous des fusées ses taux alors qu'a
répondu m6 à ces accusations
alors déjà je voudrais dire que ce qui
est dit dans la woc de l'excellent
gibier ou genton c'est faux parce
qu'elle n'est pas en colère contre m6
elle a dit si elle a dit qu'elle n'était
pas du tout en colère contre n 6 qu'elle
leur demandait juste un truc c'est
d'essayer de ne plus diffuser cette
séquence que ça lui faisait beaucoup de
mal et m6 nous a répondu vous allez me
donner votre avis sur la réponse des
petits et vous aussi
également chez vous n'hésitez pas à
réagir là-dessus la sienne est surprise
des propos tenus hier dans touche pas à
mon poste et des différentes critiques
survenu à l'encontre de cauchemar en
cuisine
en préambule il est important de
rappeler contrairement à ce qui a été
dit hier philippe etchebest n'a jamais
refusé de débattre sur le plateau de thé
pmp il n'a juste pas été invités alors
on l'a on a fait la demande
sachez le mais philippe etchebest ne
pouvait pas parce qu'il était en
tournage et ils nous ont dit qu'ils
viendraient des qui pourraient philippe
etchebest on a dit qu'on n'avait rien
contre lui ici ce qu'on a dit d'ailleurs
ici tout exactement canoniste ont dit
qu'ils ne jouait pas un rôle et il était
comme il est dans la vie c'est encore
une fois fou ils disent à propos des
déclarations de monica qui dénoncent le
fait qu'ils auraient demandé à des
clients de dire que ce n'était pas bon
c'est encore une fois faut la production
demande aux clients ce qu'ils ont
apprécié ce qu'ils n'ont pas aimé pour
nous aider à bien comprendre ce qui va
dans le restaurant ce qui doit être
amélioré
nous le disons également régulièrement
dans le programme les propos de gilles
verdez concernant le cauchemar en
cuisine de paray le monial ont par
ailleurs été remis en cause il
vous en veulent vous avez de moins en
moins d'amis et je vous défendre et
quand ils arrivent sa longue enquête de
journalistes auraient été facilitées
s'il nous avait appelés ce numéro de
cauchemar en cuisine n'a pas été
diffusée pour la simple et bonne raison
que le restaurateur a décidé de fermer
son établissement avant même la
diffusion
nous avions déjà dit que nous préférions
donc diffuser des cauchemars des
restaurateurs encore en activité pour
les aider et enfin elle explique qu'elle
ne comprend pas les attaques sur les
missions il est infondée et même assez
injuste d'attaquer un format qui mis en
place un suivi aussi important après
tournage pour venir en aide aux
restaurateurs avec qui nous travaillons
philippe etchebest s'implique totalement
dans l'aide et le suivi des
restaurateurs après tournage
ils appellent régulièrement les
restaurateurs pour savoir où on en est
où en est leur établissement mais
dépassé parfois les voir à l'improviste
sans en faire la moindre communication
voilà je vous dis donc c'est vrai que m6
a répondu à tout cela sachez que les
dernières informations m6 a laissé un
message à monica pour lui dire qu'ils
arrêtaient de diffuser grâce également à
tpm payèrent sachez qu'il ya une
cagnotte qui a été mise en place pour
venir en aide à monica voilà et julien
qui était aussi en plateau hier lui a
proposé un travail à la sortie du
plateau
que pensez-vous de la réponse de six
mois je vous savez que c'est vrai qu'on
est à ses amis avec les patrons m6 je
m'en suis jamais caché que ce soit
nicolas de tavernot frédéric de
vincelles ou thomas valentin on se parle
tout le temps et je leur ai dit vraiment
fière quand les ai eus je leur ai dit
regardez la séquence j'ai dit à fred de
vincelles qui est le directeur des
programmes d'm6 regarde la séquence
parce que il y avait vraiment un
restaurateur qui était très heureux une
autre qui a eu une expérience un peu
moins facile plus compliquée mais elle
n'a jamais remis en cause ni le travail
de philippe etchebest nom ni le travail
de m6 après qu'on scénarise des
émissions c'est normal
un début un milieu une femme raconte
également une histoire et fils de
forcément c'est ce qu'il faut faire
alors vous est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de la réponse des six marins
depuis tout à l'heure et ne laisse que
notamment sur deux points qui est
important c'est qu'ils n'ont pas répondu
un sur le fait que la jeune fille a dit
hier tous les mardis mon resto était
plaint le jour où il est allé y est
évident oui j'aurais aimé qu'ils
répondent oui ou non très sincèrement
alors qu'ils ont devant j'ai répondu ils
ont prétendu ils m'ont dit qu'ils
demandaient bien entendu comme dont
surtout les tournages des autorisations
de diffusion fabrique qui promeut et
prévenez juste les gens en leur disant
voilà sachez le si vous allez dans ce
restaurant vous risquez d'être filmé
donc cette fois sa série 13 qui
fonctionnait de faire vivre le resto le
mardi d'un des moments hivernal mais
comme elle l'a dit les mêmes personnes
toujours là il ya juste des gens qui ne
veulent pas y voilà qui vous les ont
prévenus avant qu'ils allaient faire
aller manger à côté
mais du coup ça fait un effet de vivre
parce que les gens qui rendent les mets
de côté hors des champs de caméras et du
cool ce qu'on voit c'est dans une salle
vide cinq ans les règles du jeu il faut
prévenir les gens quand ils m'ont
presque y avait beaucoup de monde
et ben moi je vais vous dire je les
félicite de leur réponse parce que
franchement elle est hyper argumenté on
peut ne pas être d'accord sur des points
mois sur paray-le-monial je suis pas du
tout d'accord je maintiens mes infos
mais c'est bien d'avoir répondu c'est
précis c'est pas agressif notre séquence
ne l'était pas non plus mais franchement
je trouve ça très sport très fair-play
grande qualité de réponse devait signer
également cédé du terrain